In the United States,
people actually own
their own images
and it's a form
of intellectual property.
So, typically the question of
what is my image
is a common sense question.
But, once AI gets into the
picture,
the question of, what is me?
What is my image?
What is the transformation
of my image,
that is an original work
becomes very puzzling.
In the particular context
that we see it now coming up
in the strikes in Hollywood,
something even more difficult
is at stake.
So if I own my image,
what happens in the world of
movies is that actors
by contract, sign away the
property in their image
to someone making a movie.
Now the question is,
what do they own?
If, by AI, I can make a
whole new movie
in which Tom Cruise is saying
new lines and doing things
he never did in the movie
did Tom Cruise sign away
his rights when he signed
away the rights to his
image in that movie or not?
AI requires us to begin
to rethink
exactly what are the parameters
of the property right
and how they have
to be protected by contract.
And of course, the strike is
about what the contractual terms
the standard terms
will be in the industry.
This is a turning point in law.
But how much difference
it will make in the real world
no one really can guess.
Predictions range on the one
hand from the apocalyptic,
This is the terminator,
when AI develops
its own self consciousness
to it's really just a toaster
that is more complicated
than our old toasters and
anything in between these
two extremes.